Can you explain why tumoxicin fit is bad?
So tumoxicin fit is an aerobotase inhibitor.
It is a very effective aerobotase inhibitor, it works really, really good.
So I wouldn't say tumoxicin is bad.
It does its job quite well and get rid of all estrogens in your body.
So it's the only thing that would be, quote, unquote, bad about it is that it doesn't job quite
well and get rid of all the estrogens in your body.
So you're getting rid of, you know, your good estrogens, not just your bad estrogens
and you could get a lot of symptoms because of that because more bones are in your body
for a reason.
However, it's really the forehead or oxy esteroids that are really attaching to the estrogen
beta receptors on the cancer cells and discouraging a contosis.
It's not the esteroids or the other, all your other estrogen metabolites or your progesterone
metabolites that are causing issues with the estrogen beta receptor.
So tumoxicin isn't specific to only the four-hydroxene esterones.
It's taking away all your estrogens and doing so it could give you a lot of symptoms.
Can you explain why mammograms are bad?
Well, well, in my opinion, mammograms, you know, are a lot of radiation for the information
that you received.
So if I was a woman and I wanted to examine where by, if I had breast cancer, I would certainly
do, if I didn't know that cancer, I would certainly do a thermography to do subscreening.
So using mammograms with the radiation that you're exposed to in a screening tool, I think
is not, well, why is you practicing medicine?
Using mammograms after you already know you have cancer increases your risk for a number
of things because your breast is squeezed between those two plates.
You could damage, you could actually, you know, damage a encapsulated tumor and cause it
to spread.
You're also radiating that for no reason.
It's not a treatment level of radiation, your damaging cells, increased number of mammograms
via a screening tool can increase a person's risk of cancer just due to the rad exposure
of radiation.
So you've got to look at any test to go, what's the value in this test, what's the information
that's gained from this test and then do I have to balance that value of that test to
the risk of that test?
Just like, you know, people will ask, well, I don't want to do a CT scan because it has radiation.
Well, I get that but there, there can be, you're, the value of the information that you'll
gain from that can't outweigh the risk.
So there's times to do a CT scan, there's time, I don't want to do an MRI because the
catalyticum and I don't want that die and that's not good for me.
I get that but then you got to weigh out is the value of the information that you're
going to gain from that test worth the risk of the radiation or on the catalyticum and you
got to weigh that out and deal with that.
That's why I always said, if you're going to do a test that is more invasive that has side
effects that come with it, then you, you have to ask yourself some questions.
Well, is the information that I gained from this test going to change the way I'm going
to treat my body?
Is it going to change the way I get the course that I get to treat that maybe I'm going to,
if this was the information that came back positive, I may do a course of radiation or chemotherapy.
If the answer is yes, I might do that.
Well, then the information always, the negativity, then go ahead and do the test.
So those are the things you have to weigh out in doing any test.